why
so as we continue our lead up to the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline in Marvel
Comics I felt like it was important to
do a video about the Silver Surfer and
this was done for a couple reasons
the first reason is because this is a
video a lot of you have really requested
a lot of you guys have really wanted to
see a video about Silver Surfer but the
other reason for this is because Silver
Surfer plays a very important role in
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline and I
would go as far as to say that the
Silver Surfer is probably second in
command so to speak to Adam warlock
during the events of the Infinity
Gauntlet but because this is a lead-up
to the Infinity Gauntlet storyline we're
not necessarily going to go in-depth
into stories involving the Silver Surfer
after the events the events of Infinity
Gauntlet what we're going to do is we're
going to talk about the silver surfers
first appearance his origins as well as
some of the events in Volume one and
eventually lead up into the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline so there will be a
video at a later date regarding the
silver surfers escapades in the Marvel
Universe after the events of Infinity
Gauntlet but it simply just won't happen
in this video but what we see with
Fantastic Four volume 1 issue number 48
is that after the Fantastic Four are
able to help the Inhumans quell the
threat of Maximus than dad attempting to
retain a talent for his own that the
Fantastic Four travel back to New York
but what we see is sort of this I guess
introduction to the Silver Surfer in
Marvel Comics and what we see is that a
silver individual on a silver surfboard
is simply just flying through the cosmos
now at this point we're not really given
any context towards the silver surfer
with the exception of the fact that he's
looking for something that he's
attempting to attain something but we
don't really know what it is what we see
is that some members of the Skrull
Empire detect the silver surfer and they
immediately begin to panic once they
identify him as the silver surfer and
this is when we get a little bit of
backstory the only thing we really
learned here is that with the Silver
Surfer whenever he arrives or whenever
he's seen that with him comes Galactus
and Galactus is the individual that
people fear not so much
Silver Surfer but because the Silver
Surfer will undoubtedly I guess lead the
way for Galactus that these Scrolls
attempt to shield their planet attempt
to shield their entire solar system from
the the Silver Surfer
so they simply just won't be detected at
this point we travel back to the
Fantastic Four and we see that when the
Fantastic Four arrive in New York that
the sky's on fire and for the most part
the Fantastic Four don't really know
what to make of this and in fact when
they get into the Baxter building I
guess when they land at the Baxter
building proper they see that for the
most part the entire citizenry is in a
state of absolute pandemonium people are
completely freaking out and they have no
real idea what's going on from here we
see the Fantastic Four are able to
restore order and the Fantastic Four of
course enter the Baxter building to try
to figure out what's going on at this
point we transition back to the Silver
Surfer
and again all this does is give us this
idea that the Silver Surfer is traveling
somewhere but then what we learn is that
the Silver Surfer is actually travelling
to the planet Earth traveling to the to
the Milky Way solar system and that he
spotted our Sun and with spotting the
the planet Earth's Sun that undoubtedly
this Sun has the ability to allow the
orbiting planets to promote life and
that the life on these planets will
exist in such a way that the planet
itself will have enough energy to
satiate the appetite of his master an
individual named Galactus from here we
switch back to the Fantastic Four and
what we see is that for the most part
Susan storm is a little irritated
because Reed Richards is spending so
much time with in his laboratory he
simply just appears to be ignoring her
she eventually breaks into his
laboratory to confront him about this
and when she does we see that Reed
Richards is accompanied by The Watcher
now this isn't the first time that The
Watcher has appeared in Marvel Comics in
fact the first appearance wasn't
fantastic for issue number 13 and that's
when we learned that the role of The
Watcher and Marvel Comics is to simply
observe but to never act and of course
Susan storm asked him about this she
says that why is it that you're acting
here when your role is to simply just
observe and The Watcher simply says that
the events as they're unfolding now the
fact
at the Silver Surfer is approaching the
planet Earth which will inevitably lead
to Galactus discovering the planet Earth
is something that's too important for
him to ignore because at this point The
Watcher has sort of become I guess maybe
a fan so to speak of the of the planet
Earth has gotten to a point where he
likes the citizenry of the planet Earth
but more so than that the super-powered
beings the Fantastic Four and various
other individuals on the planet Earth
have the potential for great
advancements in terms of just overall
abilities as well as the place of
humanity and the cosmos and so The
Watcher doesn't want to see this go away
what we learn here is that when the sky
was set fire that was done by The
Watcher it was simply an attempt for The
Watcher to guard the planet Earth from
the Silver Surfer to trick the Silver
Surfer into believing that this planet
doesn't inhabit or doesn't support any
kind of life and as a result of the
citizenry going crazy that the watcher
had taken away the the fire and simply
just encompassed the planet Earth with
this sort of space debris now he goes as
far as to say that this isn't something
that will last just because the Silver
Surfer if he's curious enough will
investigate further and discover the
planet Earth proper and discover that
this is a planet that does have the
ability to satiate the appetite of
Galactus from here we switch back to the
Silver Surfer and of course we see the
Silver Surfer has discovered the planet
Earth and almost immediately sims for
his master Galactus we also see the
Johnny Storm moves to intercept but
Johnny storm is almost entirely
outclassed by the mobility of the Silver
Surfer what we also see here is that Ben
Grimm the thing confronts the Silver
Surfer and at this point because the
Silver Surfer has already summoned
Galactus The Watcher goes as far as to
tell Ben Grimm that this is a useless
effort there's really no point in
attacking the Silver Surfer despite the
fact that Ben Grimm was able to deal a
significant enough of a punch to knock
the Silver Surfer off the building that
the issue here the concern here is no
longer the Silver Surfer that the
Fantastic Four need to take their
efforts you need to make it make it
there I guess prom objective to try to
find a way to defeat Galactus at this
point we see that because Galactus has
been summoned by the Silver Surfer that
Galactus is almost at
planet Earth that he is within the solar
system and is near the moon at this
point we reach the end of a fantastic
for volume 1 issue number 48 when we see
that Galactus has arrived and Galactus
states that the planet Earth sustains or
has enough energy that it can sustain
him his need for energy until he can
find another place and that Galactus is
going to drain all energy from the
planet Earth which would result in the
destruction of the earth itself from
here we switch to the Fantastic Four
volume 1 issue number 49 and what we see
here is that when the Silver Surfer was
knocked off the surface of I'm sorry
knocked off the top of the Baxter
building that the Silver Surfer had come
into contact with Alicia masters then of
course Alicia masters is the blind girl
friend who is also a sculpture of Ben
Grimm and we see that she begins to talk
to the to the Silver Surfer and this is
a very interesting element now probably
say one of the most important parts of
the history of the Silver Surfer and the
reason why is because at this point in
the Marvel comics the Silver Surfer
doesn't understand the base of emotions
of humans he doesn't understand what it
means for something to be beautiful he
doesn't understand what the importance
of life is for him he is simply just a
Herald of Galactus and his job is to
simply ensure that Galactus is able to
gain the energy necessary in order for
him to to sustain himself and we see
this playing out we see that of course
Alicia masters is talking to the Silver
Surfer about eating food and the Silver
Surfer doesn't understand this he says
what's the point of eating food why not
simply just turn it into energy of
course he also goes on to say that in
the end none of this really matters that
Galactus will destroy things
but as we see him continuing to converse
with Alicia masters that over the course
of this conversation he begins to
understand things like courage he begins
to understand concepts like beauty and
and what these things entail in terms of
what it means to be human we of course
see that Alicia masters is able to get
the Silver Surfer to understand that
humans have a right to live that the
desire to stay alive is something that
all organisms across the universe share
and that it's really not the place of
the Silver Surfer to stand idly by and
allow
galactus to destroy planets teeming with
life to simply support his appetite at
this point we see Galactus has assembled
his device to drain the energy from the
planet Earth something called the energy
converter and when he goes to fire it up
that it actually doesn't work and the
reason why is because ven grim is
tearing it apart from here we see that
the Fantastic Four do what they can to
launch an attack against Galactus but
for the most part they're almost
entirely outclassed what we also see
here is that the watcher has formed a
plan to to defeat Galactus and the plan
involves Johnny Storm traversing space
and time to gain some kind of a weapon
that could be used against Galactus and
this is kind of what we see going on
here we sort of see these multitude of
circumstances these sort of a separate
storylines taking place where Galactus
is able to summon a minion called The
Punisher and the Punisher is simply just
designed to fight on behalf of Galactus
to keep the Fantastic Four out of
Galactus is way we see that for the most
part Johnny Storm is attending to attain
or tending to travel to a location where
you can attain this weapon and order to
defeat Goliath and we also see that the
Silver Surfer is becoming I guess slowly
beginning to understand these these
concepts of humanity these ideas of what
it means to fight on the right side of
what good and evil mean and various
other things ultimately we see the story
conclude a Fantastic Four volume 1 issue
number 50 and what we see going on here
is that the Silver Surfer after
discussing with Alicia masters these
ideas of what it means to be human these
ideas of what it means to have the right
to life well I wouldn't go as far as to
say has given him a perfect
understanding of humanity it has given
him pause to turn against Galactus and
it has given him this idea that he can
fight on behalf of humanity to attempt
to defeat Galactus now of course because
Silver Surfer is a herald of the latus
and was created by Galactus he's not
necessarily able to destroy him however
Galactus is a little surprised to
realize that he had given the Silver
Surfer more power than he had initially
thought what we see as this comic
continues is that the weapon that was
gained by Johnny Storm to be used
against Galactus was something called
the ultimate nullifier and the ultimate
nullifier is a very important weapon in
the
of Marvel Comics because this is
something that can in effect eradicate
Galactus entirely it's exactly what it
sounds like it nullifies the concept of
energy it simply just eliminates
something from existence what we see
here is that Reed Richards with the
ultimate nullifier threatens to destroy
Galactus and Galactus once he realizes
that Reed Richards has the ultimate
nullifier makes an agreement the
agreement is that if Reed Richards
agrees to hand over the ultimate
nullifier to khalaqtu s-- the Galactus
will walk away that he will not destroy
the planet Earth and consume its energy
we see that Reed Richards is a little
skeptical about this Reed Richards
rightfully so is unsure but The Watcher
says that when a Galactus makes a
bargain that that bargain is not backed
out on that Galactus always keeps his
word and that's what we see happening
here we see that Reed Richards hands the
ultimate nullifier over to Galactus and
Galactus agrees to leave he agrees to
leave the planet earth alone and not
consume its energy but in response to
the Silver Surfer turning against
Galactus Galactus doesn't necessarily
strip the Silver Surfer of his power but
what he does is confine him to the
planet Earth and puts the Silver Surfer
in a position where he simply cannot
leave from here we transition to the
Silver Surfer vol 1 and for the most
part issue number one is really going to
be the only comic that we're going to
stick with and the reason why is because
this gives us the origin story of Norrin
Radd vol 1 as a whole is really just the
Silver Surfer traversing the planet
Earth coming into contact with various
humans and learning to understand what
it means to be human
not necessarily again going as far as
gaining humanity but simply coming into
contact with various humans saving
various humans but also being chased off
by humans because a lot of humans look
at the Silver Surfer as the individual
who is responsible for the coming of
Galactus and so a lot of people simply
just don't trust him but what we see
with the backstory of Norrin Radd is
that Norrin Radd was a member of an
unnamed alien race and the problem with
this alien race is that they had in
effect done everything they had
traversed the entire universe they had
gained all sorts of knowledge they had
all these experiences over the course of
the history of their alien Empire and as
a result they had achieved this state of
sort of I guess maybe higher
enlightenment where they
had no interest in conflict they had no
interest in war they had eliminated
disease and famine and there was really
no money system and so this was a
society that was 100% and completely
peaceful but the byproduct of being such
a peaceful society was that they didn't
have any way to defend themselves short
maybe some sort of some kind of nuclear
defensive barrier what we see is that
Norrin Radd is kind of a little
different than everybody else in his
alien race while everybody else is
content with this sort of Eloy kind of
society that they live in
Norrin Radd has always wanted to explore
he's always wanted to investigate and
see what kind of wonders are available
in the universe what we see is that
Galactus enters the solar system
belonging to Norrin Radd x' race on the
planet zenn-la and Norrin Radd along
with various other individuals simply
come up with this plan to at the very
least approach the alien craft and see
what his intentions are and to see if
there's a way that they can stop it from
destroying their planet what we see is
that when the when Norrin Radd
approaches the alien spaceship that he
discovers that the alien spaceship
houses Galactus and he begins to have a
conversation with Galactus but Galactus
stops him and tells him that Galactus
knows exactly why he's there and that
nothing that no one rad can say will
assuage Galactus of his desire to
destroy to consume the energy of zenn-la
resulting in its destruction but what we
learn here is that ultimately Norrin
Radd and Galactus come to an agreement
Galactus states that traveling from one
planet to another to consume its energy
is very exhausting for him it takes a
lot of energy out of him and that if he
had a Herald that this planet and other
planets like it could be spared and so
Norrin Radd makes an agreement with
Galactus and says that if Galactus
allows Norrin Radd to be his Herald to
travel from one planet to another that
Noren that Galactus will spares in law
and no one will carry out this role for
as long as he exists and essentially
forever and what we see as a Galactus
takes him up on this agreement but this
is when we see an interesting side of
Galactus we see think Galactus isn't
necessarily devoid of emotion Galactus
says that he doesn't like the idea of
consuming planets rich with life but
that's necessary and so he has annoying
rad are you sure about this you know is
this a decision that you want to make
because there's no backing out of this
this is not something you can walk away
from but what we see is that knowing rad
says yes
Norrin Radd says that if it will spare
his planet that he will happily
undertake the role of being a herald for
Galactus and so what we see is that
Norrin Radd is I guess rematerialized
he's transformed into the Silver Surfer
now one misconception that a lot of
people have is that when Norrin Radd
becomes the Silver Surfer that he loses
all memories of his previous life this
is not the case
Norrin Radd still retains his
understanding of who his people were of
who his girlfriend Shinhwa was he
retains understanding of all these
individuals and in fact what he does is
agreed to undertake or I guess to to go
meet with ash in LA and to tell her
what's happened to tell her that he is
the new Herald for Galactus and that
their planet has been spared but that he
will never be able to return that he
will effectively surf the spaceways and
will play out this role of searching for
planets for Galactus to consume now of
course he says that his idea here his
plan here is to always take Galactus to
planets that are uninhabited that will
not require the death of individuals or
any kind of races in order for him to
satiate as appetite but in the end of
course we see this kind of kind of
changing ways as over time Silver Surfer
begins to sort of lose this humanity he
begins to sort of lose what it was that
made him Norrin Radd which resulted in
him travelling to the planet Earth in
the first place and then calling
Galactus despite the fact of the planet
Earth was a I guess a life rich planet
with this being said this leads us into
a volume 3 as well as the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline and what we'll see as
we get into Infinity Gauntlet is that of
course the Silver Surfer has been freed
of his exile on the planet Earth and is
the first person to come across a Thanos
once Thanos is wheeling the Infinity
Gauntlet and he warns dr. strange as
well as
Adam warlock of the upcoming threat and
of course this was the result of him and
Drax the destroyer being attacked by
Thanos while Thanos wielded the Infinity
Gauntlet which will ultimately lead us
into the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
proper and all the events that unfolded
with that being said I'm going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace
you